hey guys it's Dennis to find anything
Cara and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of almost human episode 5
blood brothers bones clones um you know
like the last few episodes that I that
we've been reviewing I've been saying
like oh can we get to a bigger story arc
and stuff like weed but actually liked
this episode I liked it you didn't even
care much for it it wasn't bad it was
just it still just it again the mystery
it's just like the the crime of the week
it is it is I think it was just this one
I was much more interested in as they
blended kind of like this serial killer
but they blended like sci-fi aspects to
his serial killer named right yeah my
favorite so still the sex bots not just
because their sex box but I just like
that fuzzy for me for this show I could
take the whole like a half out of them
just in the car together that's always
with the best humorous I mean I love you
know they're in the car and he's oh no
they go to the locker room and he sees
the you know one of the newer versions
like make it it's like a Ken doll he has
like nothing down there then he said you
everything down there then he shows it
to was like oh put that away except for
all from one person he's like what do
you do with that you know I mean I love
their banter yeah the banter in the
chemistry between the two characters is
good and we're starting to see more
development between them and the other
character in in the police station like
the Maldonado the the Chi captain that's
a little bit more of her this week and
then we got to see a you know with mega
Kelly's character stall yep and even the
the one [ __ ] cop guy yeah George
always one jerk in the yes yeah so those
parts are liked and I think because in
this particular one I enjoyed the whole
thing of like how they were doing a
witnesses they're being witnesses on the
those quality and right it was being
holographic clear engine and that was
kind of a cool scene when I think the
girls about to get shot and she's like
freaking out it's kind of cool because
it's scary because everyone's like
reacting to in the courtroom but nobody
can do anything about it because she's
off site which is that was kind of which
was supposed to be safer right we
supposed to be safer which is not
and the oven army of clones coming after
you because I remember watching that I
guess that the little teaser commercial
for this particular episode and I
thought it was gonna be really cheesy
with the with the psychic and whatnot
and so I was pleasantly surprised when i
watch this one yeah the molds with her
were great that her that scene with her
and dorian at the end i like was very
nice guy kind of having some resolution
with her you know he never got talk to
her parents I guess or something like
that that was not even there's some
there's nice moments the show is still
good i'm still in it for sure I just
like you said I kind of want to auntie
that bigger story I want to see them
expand the this universe more yeah
hopefully hopefully in the upcoming
episodes they do that right I just I
just appreciate like the whole cloning
thing in the whole how he could be at
different places and they actually had
like this big gun battle yeah yeah going
down that the van and everything and
there was like One cool scene where that
was cool Dorian run out yeah yeah
they're like can they do the like he did
I never seen that before so I don't know
there was just moments in this episode
that I that I really like that for for
for at least s episode I like kind of
like forgot the whole was ok Masada yeah
yeah so I guess I hope it gets I mean
I'm still in it I like it I just hope it
gets a little bit more over the
expansive universe I want to see more of
the I wanna see what's up of the in
syndicate everybody say this I want to
see more about his old girlfriend who
was in on it like I want to see more
about that I hope they get to that cuz i
don't think the season is gonna be a
full 22-episode so weird i don't think
you know we're gonna put if it's only
like 10 or 13 episodes we're getting to
the halfway point soon's i hope we get
more of that story to the bone yeah yeah
alright guys so that's what we thought
the episode you post your comments on
the website thing CARICOM or below on
this YouTube channel think hero pro make
sure to subscribe to that you also come
check us out on twitter how to dennis
myself Michael any of us about the shows
you love and we think about almost human
if you like in the form they're doing
right now let us know we're at think
hero personally i'm at griffin de and we
have to have a facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and you know
tweet out and share our videos for the
word alright thanks
you